Let's start with the first one--let's try some experiments and I want to encourage you
to do all the experiments you can think of to try to answer a question about set.
And the quizzes that we're going to have, some of them in this unit are different
from the kind of quizzes that you had in CS101.
All those quizzes were meant to be ones that you could answer based on what had been covered,
but realize it's not like that.
These problems you face don't follow directly from previously covered content.
Many of the course in this unit will be different, that you'll need to do some experiments
on your own, may be do some web searches, may be read some documents
to try to figure out how to answer them.
Then I'll talk about how I would find the answer to that question when I discussed the answer
not so much what the answer is but more importantly how do you find it.
The question is, is the result of set x or x as a list a mutable object or an immutable object,
and you should remember that mutable objects are objects whose value can change
like list in dictionaries.
Immutable objects are objects whose value doesn't change like integers and strings.
What's the result of set x.